hi
my name is carl hoppy i'm the extension
livestock specialist at the carrington
research extension center
and today i'm going to visit about feed
rations for background in cattle and
this is the fall
2020.
this is brought to you by ndsu extension
well new calf crops are here 2020
uh time to place them on feed and look
at what type of calves we have you know
these january-born calves are going to
be big these april and june born calves
are going to be smaller
so we got a little bit of everything out
there in the pen we have different
colors we have different types
sexes uh bulls steers heifer hopefully
most of them are castrated if they're
going to the commercial market
and uh there's just a lot of differences
out there but it's a new year and a new
season a new group of calves that need
to be placed on feet
a couple comments here
traditionally in background in calves we
grow cattle
and it takes feed
in the northern plains where
backgrounding state if we're in the
southern plains we would still have
grass or some type of feed resources out
there
which to graze so in the northern plains
it ends up being a feeding state so
that's kind of the difference between
backgrounding
and stalker cattle backgrounding means
we're feeding them for a period of time
after weaning
now the feed prices follow the corn
price
that's traditionally what's been going
on and it continues to go on
that way so as corn prices are increased
so does the overall prices of other
feedstuffs
increase as well let's go through some
examples let's take a walk back in
memory lane i like to
i like to reflect on these just to have
an idea of what prices were just a few
years ago because
you know we tend to even remember we
only remember about a year back
so not even that far at times what
happened but in 2017 our corn price is
288 a bushel
and our distiller's greens was a dollar
i was 113 dollars a ton
hays were anywhere from 65 to 85 a ton
depending upon what it was and wheat
mixes were at 95 and at that time
we still had barley mulch sprouts in the
region in which to feed
in 2018 the price of corn went up to
three bucks a bushel
hay remained about the same price of
distillage grains went up slightly as
well as wheat meds and barley malt
sprouts are not available
in north made in north dakota at least
now for 2019 just last year the price of
corn did go up another 10 percent hayes
remain about the same price wheat beds
are a little bit lower
and and distillers grains reflected the
corn price and it increased as well
now let's see what's happened for 2020
corn prices increase slightly
hey in both alfalfa and grassy at least
this is alfalfa hay for
steers for beef cattle not necessarily
for dairy cattle
um have remained the same compared to
previous years wheat meds has creeped up
just a little bit distillers grains has
increased
quite a bit there's been a demand for
distillers grains and the price is up
canola meal prices are up as well
and the price of corn size because the
price of corn has increased the price of
corn silage
has increased as well
must make note we have a lot of
processing plants in north dakota some
states don't have this
opportunity that we have but if you're
located in the right location
and need some supplemental feeds the
price of these feeds
along with your freight might make it
very competitive to bring that into your
feed yard
if you're in western north dakota you've
got a lot of freight compared to being
located in eastern north dakota
distillers grains is quite prevalent
throughout the
lower part of north dakota and even into
south dakota
so uh the amount of co-product feeds
better from distillers grains is
quite readily available as well as wheat
meds
and we have uh
oil crushes throughout north dakota that
would make um
soybean meal canola meal sunflower meal
those types of things where the oil's
been taken out we do have sugar
processing plants in the state
sugar beets that is and they produce
beet pulp we used to have tailings but
most of those might be going to the new
ethanol plant that's producing
up in grand forks north dakota
here's just to run down the co-product
feeds in north dakota rather than a map
as i said we got five different
distillery grain plants like
five different ethanol plants that
produce distillers greens
uh in north dakota and actually several
more throughout the region
they produce both wet which would be
like 60 moisture
modified which is 50 moisture and dried
which is basically
dried 95 percent dry matter feed
sometimes
they produce what's called corn syrup
but its real name is condensed
distillery solubles
most of these plants put this back onto
the distillers grains that's why it's
called
distillers distillers grains with
solubles
although most time we just shorten it up
and say ddgs which is dry distillers
grains or
just distillers grains we're talking
about the water modified and for those
people that do get distillers grains
with solubles
excuse me condensed cellular solubles
they just call it corn syrup
not to be confused with the corn syrup
that comes out of
a fructose refining plant a corn a wet
corn milling plant like there is down in
waffenton north dakota
but that usually goes to the human food
industry not to our livestock feeds so
usually we're talking corn syrup and
livestock it's always just
great we do have wheat millings in north
dakota the north dakota milan elevator
is the largest
mill in the world in one location and of
course we the
the taxpayers of north dakota own the
state mill and elevator in grand forks
and they're very competitively priced
when it comes to events of course we
have
a mill up in minot carrington and
fairmont
and even some milling is done up in can
do probably mild sprouts is only done in
is it done out of state now in
moorhead uh we don't have a milk
sprouting plant well it's closed now
has been for several years in north
dakota we do have a corn gluten feed
plant
or a fructose plant wet corn milling
and produces corn gluten feed as well as
corn gluten meal
meals about 60 protein usually goes into
a lot of our
dog food type diets pet diets
not so much into our animal diets but
corn gluten feeds
widely utilized in the dairy industry
and can be in the beef industry too
uh the plant now produces only wet
product that's how much the demand there
is they don't even produce the dry
we do have a couple of potato proposing
plants in north dakota
one in grand forks one in jamestown if
you're on the list to get it year round
you are probably their favorite customer
it's really hard to get this product in
the off season but it is available
uh depending upon what the supply is b
tailings
again that used to be readily available
but now with the ethanol plant located
up in grand forks that
utilizes uh
potato waste as well as tailings um
beet tailings that they might be more
difficult to get a hold of
beet pulp is still available when the
dryers can't catch up or meet the demand
of drying down beet pulp
of course our meals kilometer linseed
mill which is from flax sunflower milk
and soybean meal are produced at several
plants across
north dakota one couple these plants are
swing plants where they produce other
it depends upon the time of the year
that they're crushing what particular
items right now we don't have a mill in
north dakota that is crushing
soybeans so consequently there would be
no soy hulls available in north dakota
but if you go across the border into
south dakota there is
plenty of million halls available in
aberdeen
of course there's always screenings that
are produced everywhere but be sure to
watch out for weed seeds that
might be in screenings the favorite one
now is palmer amaranth or
or palmer pigweed and if those seeds are
in some screenings that are brought in
from out of state you have just created
a
a very weed herbicide resistant plant
into your fields or your feedlot
and just be careful about what you're
buying when you're buying screening if
they're locally from north dakota and
sourced locally from north dakota
that problem shouldn't be there with not
swedes that can't be controlled with
herbicides
let's talk a little bit about cattle now
there is a daily nutrient need for
certain feed ingredients for cattle i'm
going to
try to lay out here that our most
expensive
costs for feeding cattle is in feeding
what we call
energy that'd be the starch and the
fiber the animals digest and utilize
to make their bodies grow a lot of times
you talk about proteins but
in reality it's the energy that costs
the most and we do buy protein
supplements to meet the needs
but usually energy is the biggest
expense so let's just use some
assumptions
we have a 700 pound steer he's eating
three percent of body weight
and that would calculate almost 18
pounds of dry matter feed
and if we look in the energy world we
can
utilize two different terms to describe
the amount of energy
the animal needs it's either in mega
cals of net energy for gain
or simply placed as tdn which
refers to as total digestible nutrients
well for easy math
we can use the 14.12 pounds of tdn
needed by the animal
and in order to get that the cost of
energy when you look at the price of
corn
and just do the calculations for the
cost per pound of tdn
it comes up to be 5 cents per bushel so
this example
14 times 5 gets 70 cents a day
for the pro for the energy cost to feed
an animal a 700 pounds tear
now they need 13.1 percent good protein
their diet if they're eating 18 pounds
of feed that roughly means 2.33 pounds
of crude protein
is needed per day good protein if you
look at the soybean meals
or the other meals um it's
18 cents a pound in this example which
means it costs almost 42 cents
a day just in protein costs so just in
that calculation alone
we spend more money and energy than we
do in protein but think of this when we
buy corn
uh we buy 80 almost 90 percent of the
corn is energy
but to eight percent of that corn or
nine or maybe even 10 percent of that
corn is going to be
protein so if we need 13
protein in the ration and we bought corn
and hay
that's averages 10 protein we only need
to
add an extra um
six tenths of a pound of crude protein a
day
so my math down there is 2.33 minus 1.74
pounds
that's the amount of protein that is in
the feed
that we bought for the energy so we need
to provide an additional
six tenths of a pound of protein to the
cattle at 18 cents a pound that means we
spent a penny
excuse me a dime so energy cost in this
ration would be 70 cents
the additional protein cost this ration
is 10 cents
and for those of you that wonder about
the cost of water roll water would cost
maybe two cents depending upon
what your rates are in your location and
the cost amount of water they
drink but i like to point that out that
water is actually a very cheap
part of our ration but energy is most
expensive
and protein while we usually talk about
protein a lot we do need protein to aid
in digestion
it's really only a small percentage the
total amount of feed that we provide
their animals on a daily basis
let's calculate some numbers for feed
value in other words cost per pound of
nutrient
the two big nutrients here are going to
be crude protein and tdm
let's take the first example canola meal
uh it's ninety percent dry matter let's
use the math on as fed basis and the
crude protein in canola meal on an as
fed basis is 38.7 percent
the cost per ton as fed would be 255
dollars a ton
the cost per pound then as adult is 12.7
cents you take the 0.127
divide that by 0.387
that's the 38.7 percent good protein and
we end up with a 29
cent cost per pound of protein that's
how we calculate
cost per pound of protein coming out of
feedstuff now we do the same thing in
calculating cost per pound of tdn
except we use that 1.27 and divide it by
0.621 that's the tdn energy of the of
canola mil
and that ends up with 0.84 we do the
same math for wheat mints corn grain and
distillers
and as you look through there what's the
cheapest
cost of protein of a tdn
we normally think corn grains the
cheapest cost to tdn and that's exactly
what our math turns out to be
it's fairly cheap and it's it's a fairly
low cost feed weed mints
is right behind it uh fairly close and
distillerish grains are somewhat
competitive
now if you look at canola mill that is
definitely not an energy source
that would use in our rations because
the high cost for energy now let's look
at the cost per pound
of protein where's our cheapest cost per
pound of protein it's actually in the
distillers grains
and then wheat mints and then canola
meal
actually are cheaper sauces distillation
grains then canola meal
then wheat mints and of course corn
green would have a very high cost per
pound of protein because it's not
utilized for protein as a protein
supplement it's utilized
as an energy supplement so
if we need energy we look towards corn
if we need protein we usually look at
protein supplements like canola meal
however distillers grains can almost be
considered one of those as both
a protein supplement as well as an
energy source
and quite frankly wheat meds falls in
that same category too
so when you start looking at rations
please keep these in mind
as two co-product feed sources
that can help balance a ration
before i get into rations i'd like to
talk about some feed issues in north
dakota
2020. this year corn silage
it wasn't as difficult for harvest as it
was in previous years but we did
like last year but we did end up with an
early frost the first part of september
we've been kind of used to having a
frost that doesn't show up until the
first part of october
so he lost about a month worth of growth
and of course when it freezes
corn choppers are they want to have
every
everybody's asking for them to show up
their place now because
corn is ready at that particular time so
the amount of delay you have from the
time it froze to the time it actually
gets chopped
affects the moisture content of the feed
and that in turn can affect the feed
value so i always encourage you to feed
test
dryer silages like this picture of the
corn was froze and you can see that kind
of a light green color in the corn
it dries out and there will be some poor
fermentation due to x and metal lead to
excess heating
so i like this temperature gauge it's a
three foot long gauge
that you stick into the size pile and it
tells you what the temperature is
just a few weeks after chopping it was
only at 82 degrees
about a month and a half later it went
up to 100 degrees which indicates
there's more
more air or fermentation going into the
into the pile
because of the lower moisture content
one other issues that we've ran into
this year is
is dry edible beans it appears there's
enough moldy
and discolored beans that producers of
dry beans can't
sell them or market them consequently
they've offered these to beef cattle
producers say can you use those
and in reality we can unfortunately we
can't use a lot
some of the research projects have shown
that if you
feed it a high degree you can actually
like 20 30 percent
even more of the diet the cattle will
just stop eating so
the recommendation comes down to limit
to 10 of the rations you might be able
to go up to 20
but watch cattle performance and if they
don't decrease in performance
continue on here's the things you'll see
with cattle there'll be digestion issues
probably some scours decreased feed
intake and actually downright feed
refusal
remember one project using great
northern bean northern
great white northern great northern
whites and
the cattle actually i think 30 or 40
percent of the ration just stopped
eating the ration and wouldn't eat
actually had to discontinue eating that
because
you know animal health they'd die if
they won't eat so
cattle might eat it for a little bit be
careful how much you can put in i
suspect if you wanted to cook these you
could probably eat more
but cooking beans before feeding the
cattle
probably isn't a realistic thing for us
in the northern great plains
here's some rations for feeding cattle
for the next four slides you're going to
have different rations for 700 pound
steers
and different rates of gain
and correspondingly different feed costs
the first one is simply 13 pounds of
grass hay
and we need some protein and energy to
add to it in order to get enough gain
because grassy itself won't provide a
two pound a day gain
but thirteen pounds of grass hay and
then seven pounds of wheat mints
will give us a two pound a day gain the
rations around the sixty four percent
tdm the cost
to feed per pound of gain is 42 cents
if you look at a little bit better gain
we have to change our rational realm we
got to increase some alfalfa hay
actually pick up some wheat mints why do
we increase alfalfa hay because alfalfa
hay has got calcium in it
well wheat meds is really high in
phosphorus and without the adequate
two to one or one to one ratio of
calcium to phosphorus you can end up
with urinary calculating cattle
you don't want kidney stones in cattle
so you need to balance the rash for
calcium phosphorus as well
this is a real deal most time we don't
have a problem with it but it certainly
can if the rations are
improperly balanced okay so this
particular ratio will give you 2.6
pounds per day gain and 37
cost a gain please note that as
our gain increases our cost of grain
decreases
now let's just use a ration that's got
we go from 2.6 to 2.8 that's not much is
it
that's just uh just a few more pounds
in this ration we used eight pounds of
hay grass hey 12 pounds of wheat mids
and we had to include limestone in an
ounce per head per day
just because of the extra calcium needed
in this ration because wheat meals are
high in phosphorus
we need to add extra calcium so a 2.8
pound a day gain
feed costs is 35 cents per pound a gain
again as we pick up the rate of gain our
cost to feed our cost per pound a gain
tends to go less
now here's another set of rations say we
put up a lot of corn sides we had alpha
alpha hay so alfalfa hey
is the queen of forages corn slides is
the king of forages in this example
eight pounds alfalfa hey 29 pounds corn
salad
you might think that's a lot of feed but
that's 29 pounds of wet feed
which would be what's one third of 29
maybe 10 pounds of dry feed
so they gained 1.8 pounds on this
particular ration
and the feed cost is 0.48 that's 35
ton corn silage and 90 dollar to an
alfalfa hay
now let's cheapen this up with some
grass hay and corn grain and wheat mitts
and in this particular example we've got
2.6 pounds per day gain feeding six
pounds of hay
four pounds of alfalfa hay two pounds of
corn
grain and eight pounds of wheat millings
and our feed cost per pound to gain is
38 cents
again as we increase the gain the cost
of the gain
goes down and if we tweak this ration a
little bit more so we're giving them
even more corn grain
and uh less al they're only going to eat
so much so we have to if we give them
more corn grain we're going to have to
back something out of the ration
we give them less grass hay and a little
less wheat mitts and now we got three
pound a day gain and our feed cost per
pound again is 3.6
so again the same true message rings
true
um that as we increase the gain
the cost of the gain goes down uh
please note that corn size you always
get this comment wow i'm feeding a hell
out of pounds out there can they eat
that much
the answer is yes because it is mostly
water they're not going to be drinking
as much water because they
ate it in their feed okay
now here's another ration a simple
alfalfa hay and corn grain
no wet feed here we can feed an all dry
ration this particular one would be 2.3
pounds a day gain
and our feed cost is 46 cents
at 2.8 let's not go backwards to slide
for a second
uh but maybe i can't now we got another
ration that's alfalfa had seven pounds
corn grain 11.5 and then because we're
not feeding enough alfalfa hay and quite
a bit of corn grain
we need to add a provide and a protein
supplement
and it's going to have extra calcium in
it as well
so it's going to be 1.5 pounds of that
particular feed and then we're going to
get a 3.1 pound a day gain it's gonna
cost us 46 cents per pound to gain
if we tweak this ration a little bit
more and decrease the alfalfa hay and
increase the corn grain a couple pounds
i will get a little bit better gain at
3.4 and our feed costs are now down to
42 cents
well now let's do another ration using
grass hay and distillers greens
15 grass hay 5 pounds of distillers feed
cost
is going to be almost 550 cents per
pound a gain
if you look at grass hay corn grain and
distillers we're at 38 cents and if we
look at grass hay corn grain distillers
and limestone because we're feeding
quite a bit of distilleries and quite a
bit of grain and and we're not getting
calcium anywhere else but it's got to
come from limestone all of a sudden
we're at 35 cents
we've got quite a spread going on here
at cost of gains
anywhere from 50 cents down to 35 cents
and when you're doing your budgets uh
this certainly comes into a
consideration of what type of
profit you'll make because if you're
paying for feed and not getting gain
you need to be careful of how you're
doing things now we should talk about
rates of gain in cattle
low rates again are considered less than
two pounds a day gain that works quite
well for
cattle that are going to be heading for
grass cattle it also works quite well
for replacement heifers
we don't need to have a replacement
heifer away 1300 pounds when she goes
out on grass she's probably gonna go
backwards
lose weight if that's the case but if
you have her 1.8 pounds a day gained
throughout the whole winter and going up
the
breeding season she'll be in good
condition away the appropriate rate
um roughly heifers should weigh eighty
percent of mature weight at their first
calving
and eighty percent of their first
calving weight
at breeding so um
we're looking at an eight to nine weight
steer
excuse me heifer when it gets to be
breeding time and a lot of times if you
do the back math
here 150
180 days on feed at a pound and a half a
day will give us
enough weight on these heifers to make
them into breeding season without
spending too much money on feed and
getting them too fleshy because we are
inventorying them
until they're breedable and ready to go
out to grass
if you're looking to grow cattle without
adding too much condition
and conditions referred to as fat two to
three pound average daily gain is where
we look at
three pounds a day for sixty days as
compared to
um two pounds a day for a hundred days
uh
different ways to grow cattle remember
if you feed them really
heavy um you might end up with fleshy
cattle which
leads us to the next light rate which
should be greater than three pounds per
day average daily gain that's almost
what we call a finishing ration
and it really would be we can feed it to
young calves have just been weaned
they're just going to get fat
at an earlier age and if you're looking
to get them
harvested less than a year of age this
might be the way to do it
however feedlights feedlots like to buy
cattle that have not been fed at these
higher rates again
because it might reduce subsequent
feedlot performance
however some cattle are genetically
disposed to gain well even without any
loss of performance
and can grow and grade extremely well
even if they're fed at higher rates of
gain so if you know what type of animals
you have you might be able to get this
by
get by with this and it works quite well
especially if you're looking to get
animals and you can feed them on your
own farm until finish
this is something that we do routinely
on calves that are brought in
weighing 5 600 pounds and trying to be
sold at
11 to 12 months of age which can be done
it just needs to be pushed
you need to look at the historical
performance of the cattle what type of
cattle they are
they'll give you insight of how you want
to manage these of course the next piece
of the puzzle is
what is the market price going to be at
the time that you're looking to sell
these cattle
and usually most of our spring-borne
calves get
fed to be dead come the summer of the
next year
and that's usually when the market low
is so we try to background cattle or
feed cattle
to avoid marketing them into that
particular time frame
otherwise we end up getting a lower
price
so we can target calf gain with a
balanced ration
i always think of a balanced rational we
have adequate amounts of energy and
protein
to give us our better gains and feed
efficiency
but when we're looking at a target
weight i think about that
as being the ideal issue of
backgrounding
so we wean calves we want to feed them
for two months so we can get them sold
after the first
year we might have three pounds average
day the gainers are go
home that'd be 180 pounds in these
calves
or we might be looking at selling these
calves six months from now into the
grass cattle market
that would be come april and people be
looking for those calves there's usually
quite a price for
green type calves and green i mean under
flesh calves that time of the year
and uh 1.5 as your average daily gain
for 120 days is going to be 180 pounds
so in these two scenarios
we feed for 180 pounds but we certainly
changed the market window
by quite a bit
and of course different market windows
can lead to different prices
you can source core product feeds in
different locations
uh there is an info sheet on this
website that
shows where there is selected prices of
co-products
that are produced in north dakota with
phone numbers and a spot market price
available there
let me just note that we can contract
feed prices to cattle
and they're usually low during the
summer
times and if you can put in if you can
estimate what your need is for the fall
time
uh you can probably get into a contract
at that lower price
rather than waiting for the spot price
and it usually gets higher after the
first year
whenever people start feeding big issue
is
when it comes to feeding co-products is
how far the freight
how far you are away from the plant or
in other words how much freight there is
some people haul a wet product hundreds
of miles and i always have to do the
math and wonder why
they are doing that there must be other
reasons other than cost to feed
maybe they're looking for a wet product
maybe they've got a trucker or somebody
they're trying to keep in business
the the real issue though is we can't
afford to haul wet
feed too far because the high price of
of uh trucking after a while it gets to
be cheaper to haul dry product
if we're hauling it it's even cheaper if
we raise it on our own farm
and produce it that way
usually for background in cattle we look
for high fiber feeds
and a lot of these coke products are
high in protein as well
a lot of our hays are usually a little
bit lower in protein so by
adding in a co-product it mixes well
with our haste increase the protein
sources
ladies uh think about good feed bunk
management good feeding management for
your calves
this is the opportunity for you to train
them and how to develop their behavior
of eating out of a feed punk
when to eat develop their routine and
that'll stay with them
so far mother has been doing the mother
cow has been doing that
to the calf they graze the morning craze
at night now it's your opportunity
to train these cattle and how they are
going to be fed
we don't want to just keep the feed
bunks full that means they can eat
whenever they want to which we do want
is to have the feed bunks
filled to what the animal's intake will
be for the day
and then we put in new feed for what
their intake will be the following day
try to have the bunks cleaned up we
usually practice what i call slick bunk
philosophy
that's where when you come out to feed
in the morning their bunk should be
all slicked up cattle have eaten
everything they need and now they're
ready to eat more
and please practice that one of the
big issues we run into is when you have
variable intake
eat a bunch today not so hungry tomorrow
and then they eat a bunch on the second
third day
not so hungry they eat a bunch more on
the fifth day in doing so creates kind
of a yo-yo effect
and the animal's steady-state condition
and room and fermentation
goes haywire and the cattle are not as
efficient
in digesting that food as compared to
having
a meal every day at the same time don't
forget bedding we've done research at
the carrington research extension center
that shows where bedding can
improve average daily gain in these
calves
and uh and it's not because they're
eating the bedding it's because
it's a nicer environment for them to lay
on
water should be kept clean so cattle
will be readily
willing to drink it try to reduce the
amount of mold you feed the cattle
if you do feed it you'll notice there
will be digestive upsets especially in
these young calves that are just
developing onto a new ration
you can keep cattle healthy whether it
means antibiotics in the feed with a
veterinary feed directive
or working them through a shoot and
giving antibiotics if they're snotty or
just brief vaccinations there's a lot of
things you can do to keep cattle healthy
and when healthy
cattle are healthy they consume
lots of feed and grow very well adapt to
ration
slowly in other words we start with a
step up ration one that's higher in
forage and lower in
energy content and as the cattle are
filled up we
after three or four days or a week or
two weeks we
bump them up to a higher energy ration a
step up ration that would have a little
bit more
grain in it and then we might do that
two or three times depending upon
what our goal for rates of gains are we
just don't dump a whole bunch of grain
out there and hopefully they don't get
acidosis and die on you
that certainly is something that can
happen so that's why balanced
rations and step up rations are
certainly utilized by nutritionists
and it works quite well the old thumb
rule way of feeding is you give them a
couple pounds of grain
along with all the hay they want to eat
and then in two days we give them a
couple pounds of grain and another half
a pound of grain
and do that plus a full feet of hay
we do that for a few days and when
they're adapted to that rash then we
increase it again by another
half a pound for two days and keep
moving up the grain part of the ration
until the cattle have matched your
target goal
ration that you're using for whatever
gain it is we're looking for
again balance ration there's lots of
feed nutritionists
whether it be your county extension
agent or a feed company
that provides this service there's lots
of ways to put together rations for
cattle
and let's not forget there are the
things that can
prove feed efficiencies in cattle
ionophores remits in their bulb attack
can improve feed efficiency
by five to seven percent implants the
ear implants can increase average daily
gain
because there are steroid that'll in and
they can increase it by five to seven
percent
and your feed per pound of gain can be
improved by five to twelve percent
these things can also control
coccidiosis
um if you ever run into coccidiosis
outbreak in a group of cattle you'll
wish that never happened
and you will do anything in the future
to prevent that from happening
and use the onofores or declinate or
co-rid
our options to our feed things that we
can add to the feed
to prevent coccidiosis of course
coccidiosis is usually an opportunistic
type thing that
always develops after a stress so if you
have a blizzard
that would be a stress cold weather can
be a stress co-mingling cavity others
new stress
just being lean can be a stress so pack
all these stresses on top of each other
and coccidiosis might break out
especially if you make a diet change or
a ration changes iron energy
that can lead to an additional stress so
only one stress at a time don't stack
them up and make them endure and then
you end up with a health issue
well in summary here let me just say
that it looks like feed prices are
higher this year
as true this year is in other years
higher average yearly gains
usually have a lower cost per pound of
gain
we have lots of options out here in
developing rations we tend to always use
distillers grains and rations because of
where it's priced
and the availability and it is quite
availability quite available
but there are other feeds that are
available out here too and we can use
those if that's what you need
co-products are usually higher in
protein and fiber
and actually work into a background
ration very well
in a finishing ration maybe not so much
because they just don't have the overall
energy density to be included at a high
rate in the
in the ration but certainly a smaller
percentage could work
and again your management in feeding
goes a long way to good calf gains if
they're used to being fed at
eight o'clock in the morning keep them
fed every morning at eight o'clock
making different changes going a little
bit earlier going a little bit later
all leads to behavioral changes in
cattle that can lead to poorer gains